i didn't put anything out about the
whole dave chappelle netflix special
thing i didn't want to didn't want to
watch it didn't want to talk about it i
do however want to say a few things
about the fallout that's been happening
with that first of all i fully support
any and all members of the netflix staff
who have decided to walk out and protest
of this because you know what netflix um
you don't get to talk about all the good
things you do all the inclusivity you do
and then release something that is also
actively harmful we're not just gonna
sit here and be okay with that anymore
and that is the message that you should
be taking from this clearly however
they're not because the current head of
the company has put out a statement
saying he believes that content causes
no harm well um first of all that's been
demonstrated not to be true content has
an impact on those who watch it in the
world around them but even if it was
that means that your content causes no
good either so you get no credit for
anything you ever do it either causes
effects or it doesn't if it causes
effects it goes both ways